we finished the paper and we thought we
have this really quite nice result and
so we uh submitted the to the journal i
knew that we were going to have this
problem because i'd had a similar
problem before when i wrote a
paper which we entitled cosmic springs
and the journal we submitted to
wrote back saying this is very nice
piece of work but the title won't do and
we had to make it a very technical title
so i thought this might happen
and anyway we submitted it off but
within an hour of submitting it to
physical review
the
editor who was in charge of it wrote
back it was quite a funny reply way he
wrote as far as i know the beatles have
made no contribution to the field of
cosmology and uh basically he was
telling telling us to get rid of all
references to
george paul ringo and john
okay so this is a paper that i've
recently written with their two
colleagues here at nottingham and
another colleague in france and the
title of the paper is general second
order scalar tensor theory self tuning
and the fab four so obviously
the curious bit about that is the bit at
the end which is the fab four which does
refer to
john paul george and ringo and four lads
from my hometown that uh went on to form
the beatles this is a is a serious
scientific paper it uh it presents a
solution or a possible solution to one
of the most difficult problems in
physics which is the cosmological
constant problem and as i said we're
trying to solve this this this very
difficult problem we started with
something very very general and we
managed to
really reduce our theory down to four
key elements and so it was given how
difficult it was and how general it was
in the beginning the fact that it
reduced to four very simple key elements
one stage we thought it was seven so we
called in the magnificent seven but then
we actually realized that three of those
were were sort of trivial so we
seven became four well i'm i'm from
liverpool so i was born in the same
hospital as john lennon um so you know
it's kind of close to my heart
these are our sort of four key elements
of the theory which is this is the sort
of really what describe the theory we
don't have to worry about you know what
this means but as you can see we've
named them john
paul
george and ringo okay so so yeah so we
sent it off to the uh to the journal and
it immediately came back without having
been
assessed by by any any experts just
saying um
there's no way we're gonna publish uh a
paper with all these references to the
beatles in it uh in view of the beatles
limited contribution to cosmology
so what happened next is basically we
had to change it we had to cave in
really we didn't have much choice in the
matter uh because it's important to get
these papers into journals and the
scientific content is certainly good
enough to manage that
so we just had to call john
number one paul number two
george number three and ringo number
four which is not quite as colorful the
fab four lives on uh because in in
certainly in our field of research the
way that uh
we submit papers now it's kind of a dual
process
um in particle theory you submit your
papers once you've finished them you
submit them to an electronic archive
and that electronic archive every day
gets updated with new papers
and then
you can you can submit that the paper
you've
sent to the archive you can also submit
it to a journal for refereeing
so we submitted it to the archive and
it's living on the archive and it's
downloaded and it's been referenced
quite a few times it's kind of there now
it's done and actually we're going to
write another paper on this subject and
we'll certainly be referring to it as
the fab four so it's set in stone now
and
one day the journals are just gonna have
to accept that
george
ringo paul and john don't appear
in the ones submitted to the journal but
apart from that they're the same we've
we haven't changed anything else
academic papers are very serious
important things and this sounds like
some pretty serious highbrow work
why would you put a joke and something
funny in it why do you do it in the
first place i mean because we're a fun
group
we enjoy our work
if you don't enjoy your work go and do
something else earn a lot of money doing
something else we for us it's um
it it you know the calculations we've
done out are correct as far as we know
and they're they're all done very
seriously and we get we got together on
a regular basis all of us to discuss it
and check things
and it was towards the end that uh we
realized that with these four terms
emerged and we just when you when you're
writing your notes you
just rather than calling them a b c d we
thought well
let's call them let's give them a name
so we're trying to
basically attack the cosmological
constant problem
which is
probably the hardest problem or the most
embarrassing problem in physics today we
look out in the in a universe around us
and imagine you you took out all the
planets and all the stars the universe
would be empty but it wouldn't mean that
it had zero energy it would have what we
call a vacuum energy well we can see the
effect
of the vacuum energy on on the expansion
of the universe so one thing that a
vacuum energy will do to a universe's
expansion is it will it will cause its
expansion to accelerate the space the
space itself is getting bigger but
gravity is an attractive force
so strictly speaking
an attracted attractive force will slow
down an expansion
that's not what's happening that's not
what we're seeing
and one of the explanation explanations
for that is that it's actually vacuum
energy that's causing it to accelerate
so what what the vacuum energy does is
it turns that deceleration into an
acceleration so the big question is
where does vacuum energy come from like
well
the vacuum the vacuum energy comes from
a vacuum but then you count you look at
particle physics and you say okay let's
try and count what we think the vacuum
energy should be we can observe what it
is but let's try and work it out from
first principles you look at say the
electron and you see that the electron
contributes some vacuum energy from it
it has its own vacuum in here it
contributes some energy to the vacuum
all the other particles do the same
and when you add all this up you realize
there's a huge mismatch between what you
expect to see and what you actually see
so what people
some people expect is that for example
that actually the vacuum engine is zero
but perhaps quantum corrections give you
a very small vacuum engine this would be
the dream some symmetry
of nature
takes the vacuum energy to zero and
quantum corrections make it sort of
slightly you know slightly just above
zero
for example but this is very very hard
to do to find that symmetry
that takes you to zero vacuum energy in
the first place that's what we've set
out to do we've set out to try and try
and find that
and uh our starting point was was really
we started looking at the way gravity
behaves
so
to try and understand how gravity
behaves is you think of it from a
particle physicist's point of view i
mean we often talk about gravity as
being
curvature of space and time that's like
that's like the relativists view of
gravity i want to think of this from a
particle physicist's point of view
and what gravity is or what any force is
actually
is the exchange of virtual particles we
exchange particles so the earth is
exchanging particles with with the sun
you and i brady we are there's a small
gravitational attraction between us and
uh
we are exchanging virtual particles
these are called gravitons now you can't
just grab a graviton at
you know just at some point the
gravitons that were exchanging you can't
just grab it right
they're virtual they you know
you can't just isolate one like that
well we said
what would happen if you
if something else helped to mediate the
gravitational force so there wasn't just
exchange these gravitons that were
exchanged of other particles too
so
we took the simplest scenario which is
that you the gravitational force comes
from the exchange of these gravitons
plus
what we call a scalar particle
and this is just a particle that has no
directional dependence it's very simple
the higgs particle they're looking for
at the nh lhc
that's an example of a scalar particle
so so we asked the question what's the
most general theory describing gravity
that involved the exchange of gravitons
and this scaler what's the most general
theory you could write down
and we uh
to our surprise we discovered that some
obscure phd student in the in the 70s
had actually found this
um a guy called hondesky hondeski and
actually discovered what this theory was
now it was very complicated how he wrote
it
and when we
discovered this we were thinking of a
similar thing but we we decided to do a
search to see if anyone had done
included this scale of field and we
found on disc is work and it was written
down in quite a complicated way it's a
big long expression
can this theory solve the cosmological
constant problem are there corners of
this theory that sort of the
cosmological constant problem
and
so we asked that question and we said
right let's let's essentially put this
theory through
our cosmological constant problem filter
let's demand that this theory can solve
it so essentially it gives us that extra
symmetry that solves the cosmological
constant problem and out popped the fab
four
it's remarkable we had such a
horribly complex theory
really complex theory and i'll pop these
four
very simple
sort of building blocks to what what is
a solution essentially to the
cosmological constant problems it they
are they are the building blocks for the
symmetry that allows you to uh set that
vacuum energy to zero uh there's terms
that are a rise in uh ex explaining the
theory there's four key terms that's why
the four are there there's a lot more to
test for example we need to test that
they can give a viable cosmology not
just that they can
you know degravitate the vacuum engine
but that actually they can give us a
viable cosmology you know over a long
period i like this one i i like it not
least because we had great fun doing it
and we're still working very actively on
it but it's an it's a nice idea i think
i really think it's quite a nice idea it
may all collapse
i mean it could be that when we begin to
work out quantum corrections to this the
whole thing breaks down on us not only
that we need to be able to get reproduce
the gravitation gravity we see in the
solar system and that's not trivial to
do this but but actually the fact that
you've got these gradients here might
might help in that regard let me be
upfront about the the actual solution
that we
this thing eventually goes to doesn't
seem to be quite what we're at today but
what it provides you with is an initial
way of getting rid of the problem of
this big cosmological constant
and that's the that's the key ingredient